[Music]
congratulations on the show it's it's
it's going when you're enjoying it
oh I I enjoy it it was like one of those
things when I call I'm so excited to
have my own show I get to do things that
you know most shows can't do like you've
got standards and practices who tells
you what you can and can't say I don't
really have that they let me as long as
you've got offensive in the title you
can say whatever you want got him right
but after I did the first shot was like
oh we did it like that's so great and
they're like yeah yeah you've got nine
more this season and I kind of panicked
a little bit I was like oh my god I feel
like doing your show is fun having a
show not as much fun it's more pressure
do what I mean yeah you show up every
day exactly four days a week four days
we do this once every two months
wouldn't you be happier you know what I
wouldn't show up I think that's the
thing is like it's the rhythm of every
day that's what you find if you get into
if someone said you've come up with a
show Kona you'll have to do a show but
you only were responsible for one a year
I would be drunk I wouldn't show up for
it yeah that's what I want you want that
you're your show is as I said it's it's
quite tease the word overused word edgy
has the network asked you to to tone it
down a bit a little bit it's weird
because Comedy Central is owned by
Viacom which is like a giant corporation
so I get phone calls from Sumner
Redstone almost every day saying Anthony
you're the face of the network we need
you to be edgier
you've been more offensive you get phone
calls from Sumner Redstone he's one of
the richest men in the world he has a
big fan and just a really edgy guy he's
like why haven't you talked about 9/11
this week I'm like that's what a lot of
people would be offended by that he's
like you're the face of the company make
more 9/11 jokes and he'll send me 10 to
12 jokes that he's written makes me do
some new redstone does that since we
have a picture here of Sumner Redstone
yeah this guy is calling you up he looks
like the guy who married Anna Nicole
Smith very edgy guy very offensive and
he's easy he's an offensive man insanely
yeah and just cut Wow
I I believe he would like if someone if
I called you on the phone you would say
hello yeah he uses the n-word
yeah yeah
have you got a lawyer I'm gonna have to
get one yeah stand up back dude you said
you say a lot of unflattering things in
your stand-up act about your family yes
throw them all under the bus yeah big
time do they get upset they did in the
beginning like my mom would be walking
on the street and someone would say I
saw your son on Conan and he made a joke
about you having an affair I didn't know
you had cheated on your husband and she
say I've never cheated on my husband
Anthony why are you making these jokes
but now that I've gotten insanely famous
now family members are begging me to get
put into jokes oh my Uncle Tom will say
like I want to be in a joke and I'm like
you know I'm gonna make you a racist
child molester right and he's like
that's great I'll do the joke I'll say
it on TV and I'll call him die Uncle Tom
what'd you think of that joke okay
thanks so then he's not so happy after
he teaches public school
doesn't work out so well Uncle Tom the
roasts you really you know you you you
came to fame doing these roasts for
Comedy Central and you enjoy the roasts
I mean because I've seen you sometimes
have to follow tough tough act they
always make me follow whoever they think
is gonna do the worst because I've got
like short jokes that I can just like I
can kind of hit them where they'll sit
put me after like Mike Tyson who's just
kind of like reading a poem or for 20
minutes or put me after the situation on
the Trump roast which is like a disaster
so there was like put me in the worst
spot possible because I think I can
clean it up right which is are you able
oh you do oh yeah you're quite confident
yeah I just have a proven track record
that I can go back to now is this true
that you did a show for the Boys and
Girls Club my am i right about that
unfortunately yes
I don't do
I don't get asked to do a lot of charity
benefits but the Boys and Girls Club was
like hey would you want to come do this
benefit for us we'll give you some money
and I don't usually this was back then
they wouldn't get paid for a lot of
stuff so it's like yeah I want to do it
but are you sure you want me and they're
like yep we're sure and I was like
here's a clip of me watch it and then
call me again they call me back like we
want is we want you and I said we'll
watch it again with the sound all the
way up and they're like yeah we want it
and then I went and did it and it was
people were very upset
[Laughter]